plaisir termina plus belle saison de son
histoire par une victoire assurée de
monter pour la première fois en
nationale 3 les jaunes est loin se sont
imposés lors de l'ultime journée contre
draveil dans un match sans enjeu le
score 34 à 31
le base nous on n'aime pas perdre et on
voulait pour le dernier match à domicile
voilà une petite victoire au public
c'était pas notre meilleur match loin de
là mais bon c'était pas l'important est
plus important c'était c'était vraiment
il ya trois semaines contre eux ou voilà
on avait à coeur de gagner celui là et
là on l'a gagnée pour le public mais
pour nous alors on a on sait juste le
plaisir va bien avec cette victoire
plaisir termine sa saison avec un bilan
de 20 victoires un nul et une seule
défaite
les statistiques affolantes qui ont
permis à l'équipe de terminer en tête de
prénationale à quatre points d'avancé
sur le second volet athlétique
cette montée était attendue depuis 13
ans par les supporters donc je pense que
ça représente énormément pour le public
pour le club les anciens du club lequel
tous les dirigeants les bénévoles les
petits enfin c'est vraiment vraiment une
grande famille c'est pour tout le monde
voilà c'est pas que nous c'est pas que
les 12 c'est vraiment un un club qui
avec lui ce moment là tous ensemble et à
une chose c'est de faire la fête avec
eux ce soir après les festivités les
plaisirs or ont déjà les yeux rivés sur
la saison prochaine est l'objectif
numéro 1 le maintien faut tout se
remette au travail parce que
va falloir tout au moins maintenir
l'année prochaine et puis travailler de
manière à pouvoir continuer à amener le
faux j'ai essayé de mener le plus haut
possible
donc vous savez ça rapporte mais avant
de penser à la saison prochaine place à
la fête
[Applaudissements]
coc
m
à